[Music]
we're here to talk about cost-effective
cluster sharing with gke multi-tenancy
if you listen to yesterday's keynote you
heard a al menorah talk about how it is
very important for our customers to
deliver value to their own customers
quickly and to be able to iterate
quickly I'm sure this is very important
to all of you as well and of course our
customers and us well want to deliver
value to your customer at the minimum
cost possible so we're here to talk
about how AG ke multi-tenancy strategy
fits into this picture
my name is Katerina Probst I work at
Google and I'm going to spend a few
minutes talking about why gke
multi-tenancy is something that you
might want to consider shied Masoud
we'll talk about the what and the how of
multi-tenancy and then finally Carl
Eisenberg from cruise automation will
give us a customer perspective a
real-world scale use case of
multi-tenancy in practice so let's spend
just a couple of minutes talking about
why multi-tenancy at a glance kubernetes
is a user or a set of users interacting
with a master master holds the API
server the scheduler other things and
the master is responsible for managing a
set of nodes that run your actual
application right so when you have one
cluster and one user things are
relatively straightforward right user
interacts with the master master manages
the nodes but what happens when you have
multiple users in multiple clusters so
think for for instance if you have many
teams in your own organization that have
to run different applications or you
know even external customers that run
different applications so what happens
when you set up a separate culinary
stack
for each one of you each one of your
users and I want to give you two things
to think about going back to our cost
and velocity arguments so think about
how the scales financially having a
completely separate stack if you look at
this one of the things you will notice
is that you now have a proliferation of
these clusters right and one of the
things that you now don't have the easy
ability to do anymore is to share
resources among these applications this
is something that we hear from customers
and they're also gels with my own
experience often times what you have is
you have applications that run at
different times of the day so you might
have some applications that take a lot
of user traffic during the day and then
you might have some applications that
you can run for instance batch
applications that you can run at night
and you want to have the ability to use
one set of resources to run both of
these easily another thing to think
about is how does this proliferation of
clusters scale operationally this is
also something that's very close to my
heart if you have a lot of different
clusters running now you have tens or
hundreds or thousands of dashboards that
you need to understand and manage now
you have to figure out how to apply
policies across all of those
consistently you have to figure out how
to apply for instance networking or
other kinds of setups consistently
across all of them how do you roll out
new versions and so forth so those are
the kinds of things where if you reach a
certain scale it becomes more difficult
to manage all of these clusters now an
alternative to this approach of setting
up a separate cluster for each app is to
have a shared cluster so a multi-tenant
cluster and the way this will work
generally is that you have a large
cluster with a large set of nodes and
you split it up by namespace and assign
an application to a namespace and now
you can have multiple users that own
different applications running in the
same
cluster1 pattern that we've seen and
that Karl will talk about him in greater
detail is different teams having their
different applications that run in
different namespaces as I just said on a
shared kubernetes cluster a set of
kubernetes clusters and then that also
gives you the ability to build platforms
on top of that that again gets you to
this place where you can be far more
consistent across all of the apps that
are running on these shared clusters now
with that I will hand it off to my
colleague try it and he will talk about
the what of multi-tenancy and the in the
house all right
so first let's try to be on the same
page in terms of what multi-tenancy
means in our context we're looking at
features that are part of kubernetes
engine that support multi-tenancy and
from the kubernetes engine point of view
the things that we want to be able to do
are to provide isolation and fair
resource sharing for the users of a
cluster within one single cluster so we
want to make sure that the users aren't
able to hog resources or step on each
other's toes as they're sharing one
cluster in a multi-tenant environment
the other thing to understand is what
your tenants are like so you can think
of your tenants as whether you trust
them whether you somewhat trust them or
whether they're untrusted so a trusted
tenant would be teams within one company
where do you know what kind of code
they're deploying you may have some
audit processes or some other checks and
balances that make sure that only
certain type of components get deployed
in your cluster so that's what I mean by
a trusted tenant they could be you may
not have as rigorous audit procedures in
place and and the tenants you still
trust them but they can deploy any sort
of code in the cluster as well and on
the other extreme you have non trusted
users or tenants who can deploy anything
basically you're providing a platform
where users bring their code and they
run their code in your platform so if
you are you have the non trusted
and you may want to look at this new
feature with GK II called GK sandbox
which uses G Visor
to add an extra layer of security
between the container and the
infrastructure so it it provides defense
and depth capabilities without requiring
much change in the in the application so
you may want to see this session which
we will talk more in detail about
multi-tenancy using sandbox back to this
session we are focusing mainly on the
use case where you trust the tenants and
you know the kind of code that they're
deploying in the cluster so with that
out of the way let's look at how you
might implement multi-tenancy there are
four things that you want to be careful
of when you're when you're setting up
multi-tenancy you want to setup the
right access control you want to set up
the right way of resource sharing a fair
way of resource sharing you want to be
able to isolate certain you certain
users and workloads from other workloads
and users and then you finally want to
see what your users are actually doing
you want to see how much resources
they're using and and so on and so forth
so let's look at each in detail first
let's look at access control so GCP at a
higher level provides a mechanism of
access control using projects and
identity and access management so
project is a is a high-level primitive
which allows you to sort of group
resources and then allows you to provide
roles to users within for those
resources so one key takeaway here is
that when you add a rule for in for a
user for a project it applies to all the
clusters in that user so if you give
someone the kubernetes engine developer
role for a project they'll have that
role for any clusters that are contained
in that project so for that reason one
thing that we recommend to our customers
is to separate your environments at
least in different projects so your
production environment should be one
project and your non prod could be
another project as well so that way if
you give someone access to the non prod
they don't automatically
have access to the production
environment as well so that's one key
point to remember and then within within
the clusters you have the boundary of
namespaces that you can use to separate
out different users and tenants within
the cluster so next let's look at what
matter how the the users are
authenticated and authorized to use
resources in a cluster so it's a
three-step process there's
authentication authorization and then
there's admission control the
authentication is provided by the I am
that we saw earlier so the roles that
the users have in the project would
determine whether they can access this
cluster or not and at a minimum you need
the get permission on the the container
API of gke
to be able to access this cluster and
then it's up to the role based access
control that are part of kubernetes that
determine what that user can do in the
cluster so you want to setup the right
roles and and and bind those roles to
those users so the roles come in two
flavors and kubernetes one are cluster
rules which are cluster wide so you want
to be careful as to who you give those
roles because these cluster rules go
across namespaces and since you're
limiting your tenants to individual
namespaces you're most likely going to
need to create the rules for each
namespace and then give those roles to
the appropriate users of that of that
namespace and you can also you can you
can create you can bind these roles with
Google Groups as well this is a new beta
feature that has come out a lot of our
customers were requesting this feature
so that they can assign the roles or
cluster roles to Google Groups and then
manage users by adding and removing them
from those groups then the next step in
the process is admission control so
before and kubernetes resources
persisted kubernetes make sure that it
meets your your admission criteria and
this is an opportunity for you to modify
that and allow and disallow certain
objects or you can change those
objects to add some default values or
you know change them to meet your policy
so that's another mechanism that's
available to you to do that one more
feature so those are for the users how
about the workloads that are running in
your system so this is another area
where our customers have to do some
manual workarounds to get past that we
have a new feature which is hitting beta
soon called workload identity what it
allows you to do is use GCP service
accounts to give your workloads access
to DCP resources without you having to
manage the keys or providing these keys
to the pods GCP will take care of that
for you and this resolves a number of
workarounds that our customers had to
implement in the past and you know in
typically you either use the identity of
the node where the workload is running
to access GCP resources but you can
imagine in a multi-tenant environment
that's not desirable because the same
node can be hosting different types of
work of workloads for different users so
you don't want to do that and it also
takes the burden away from from the
administrators of either downloading the
key and then manually managing that key
and providing that to the workloads that
they want so that's a great new feature
too that supports multi tenancy and
there's a detailed talk on that feature
also that you may want to look at to
understand that feature in more detail
so next let's look at resource sharing
kubernetes as I said has a lot of lot of
sort of mechanisms built into it to
allow you to do that you can define
quotas which is the aggregate sort of
resources that a namespace can have you
can add default values for resource
limits and and requests that you want
that the users can make for their
workloads you can also use pod at an odd
affinity and endi affinity to sort of
split the workloads on across different
nodes and and sort of isolate them from
each other and then pod identity per pod
priority can be used to sort of
prioritize different workloads
or the other so high-priority workloads
can preempt lower priority workloads as
well next let's look at runtime
isolation again there are a number of
features I already mentioned sandbox
pods that you can use to provide an
extra layer of security between the
containers you know and and audit what
the containers can do you can also set
up the pod security policies and
security contacts which limit which
allow you to limit what the pod can what
resources the pod can access whether it
can access the file system or it can run
in the host network and so on and so
forth and network policy also allows you
to determine which pods are able to
communicate with one another what in
what sort of network access those pods
are allowed so these are sort of
primitives that are built in to either
kubernetes or the kubernetes engine that
you can use one challenge that this
poses is there's a lot of policies that
you have to manage how do you apply
those policies across multiple multiple
clusters that you might have and
namespaces within those clusters and
also how do you ensure that the that the
policies that you want applied don't
drift people don't come in and change
the policy and you want to have better
control on that policy and that's where
a new feature called anthos config
management comes in how many of you
watched the keynote yesterday
so the keen observers may have seen the
anthos config management being used
during the demo that we showed for
anthos to apply the different policies
or changes to your cluster what it
allows you to do is to define your
policy in in a central place you can
check that into a repo so you can wonder
version control that and then config
management will automatically pull that
policy and apply it to all the clusters
that are enrolled in that config
management so I'll give you a brief demo
of that to show how that works so I have
a cluster where I don't have any
workloads running right now and I have
defined
my policy into this repo that I have and
you can define any kubernetes native
resource it doesn't have to be just
those policies you can you can define
the quota here I have a quota defined
where I can have 70 pods in each
namespace and so on and I can also
define deployment so if you wanted to
have some workloads running by default
in those namespaces you can you can
define that as well so I have this you
know this this workload that I'm running
in this namespace as well so next what
I'll do is I will apply that policy in
that cluster so I have the config
management operator already running in
the cluster and this is the operator
that's looking at at custom resources
that define where your policy should be
pulled from so the way you do that is
you you define a custom resource of type
config management and you point it to
the repo where your policy exists so in
this case I'm pointing it to the repo
that I just showed you and I can specify
which branch it should pull the policy
from and apply to the cluster so I'm
using master depending on your own sort
of you know branching policy you can
choose the branch that you want so what
I'll do next is I will apply this policy
into my cluster
and what that is doing is essentially
what this will do is it will create you
know that policy in the cluster so one
thing you'll notice is if I go back to
the workloads it will start a few
processes that will start pulling the
the policy from the git repo and start
applying it or in your cluster as well
so once this this policy has has been
applied what you will notice is that
anything that I've defined in this repo
will be applied to that to that cluster
and the the namespaces that I've defined
blue and green and common and the quota
that I've defined will be applied to
that cluster as well so while that is
while the the policy is applied I just
want to point out a few things here one
thing is that you can since your policy
and all of your resources are checked
into a repo you can use your your sort
of build pipeline to make sure that any
changes in the policy are validated
through some tests they reviewed
whatever process you have for the review
and then once the review is complete and
you merge those changes back into the
branch that you want to apply it to the
cluster that config management will
automatically deploy it in the cluster
for you and another great feature of
config management is that if someone
tries to go in the cluster and change
some of those policies they try to
change some of those values config
management will detect that change and
it will reapply that change back in the
make sure that the cluster conforms to
the check den policy in the repo so it
will it will continuously reconcile the
changes in the policy with with what's
in the repo so let's go back and see if
this has started so as you can see it
started that and the other thing that
you would notice is the hello world
deployment that I had defined in here is
now has been has been created in the
cluster as well so let's say if you
wanted to change some of those so let's
say I want to
change the you know change the Kota I
want to make a change so what I can do
is I can again follow my workflow for
pushing changes to the git repo
so here I have a change that I made to
the quota that I want to apply to the to
the to the repo to them to the cluster
as well so what I will do is I'll add
that change and then I will commit that
change
and once I push that change into the
into the repo config management will
automatically apply that change into the
cluster and now if I look at the Kota in
that namespace what you will see is that
the Kota is 15 and a 50 and it has
changed from 72 down to 50 so this is an
easy way to make sure that your policies
always stay in sync with what you have
whatever you define in your Ipoh so
getting back so this there's a more
detailed session where we talked about
the config management so you may want to
check out that session as well it's
later tomorrow so let's finally look at
how do you get to know what your tenants
are up to in the in the cluster as well
so for that we have a new feature in gke
called usage metering what it allows you
to do is capture the resource usage that
your users have in in the namespaces
that they've been assigned to so you can
capture usage of memory CPU and other
resources in the cluster it will put
that data in a bigquery data set that
you can later analyze and visualize as
well the important thing is this does
not automatically generate the billing
data for those tenants but you can
combine that data with your billing GCP
billing data to figure out how to bill
your tenants as well and you can
visualize that that data using something
like data studio to see what your
tenants are doing so these are just some
of the features that can help you set up
multi-tenancy but we have you know a
real use case from cruise automation and
I'd like to invite Carl to come up here
and walk us through their use case
hey I'm Carl and I'm the tech lead
manager of the paths team at cruise
cruise is doing self-driving vehicles in
San Francisco if you've been around here
while you've probably seen our cars
driving around San Francisco and we try
to connect people with the places things
and experiences that they care about
doing this this is a visualization from
one of their one of our other open
source tools that you can find more
information about on our blog but it's
basically visualizing the lidar game
data and our mapping data together so
one of the problems we had at cruise
when I started probably a year and a
half ago is a cluster polar
proliferation problem so we had a whole
bunch of sres that were deploying
kubernetes clusters on AWS at the time
and what we ended up with was like one
cluster per team effectively some of
them were sharing some of them weren't
and they were all kind of special little
snowflakes most of them weren't
upgradable some of them had like
defaults still configured like 1-year
time bombs on the route CA which would
then expire and then lead people to
frantically replacing them so one of the
ways we we solve this later was moving
to gke but the way we did immediately
was to start up a PA's team to work on
sort of centralizing the development of
a platform as a service at cruise on top
of kubernetes at cruise we have a lot of
workloads that are fairly diverse so we
we do ml and data processing back-end
services reporting batch jobs
productivity tools continuous deployment
continuous integration platform add-ons
and a lot of these were already in
containers so we were pretty cloud
native we're just trying to you know
become more production ready before we
launch our services in the coming years
so some of the reasons why we went into
multi-tenancy or what we decided to
invest in multi-tenancy one was cost
savings we we already recognized that we
were spending a bunch of money on these
masters running kubernetes clusters and
we didn't really need
because we weren't maximizing the
masters in our proliferating clusters
they also weren't even highly available
masters so moving to a central cluster
allows us to move faster with that
central cluster and get it to a more
production ready mature state which
helps us towards our production
readiness goals of you know being easier
to audit having central observers
observability having dashboards that
were mature built-in backups auto
scaling all that kind of stuff
that if you spread out to your teams
they might not get even in the same pace
or even ever and then the other thing we
were we care about a lot was developer
productivity or velocity and so some of
this was around centralizing the ingress
and egress for for Nats and load
balancing and some of it was around
centralizing config management and image
building and continuous deployment
basically all trying to get our
developers to have to consider less of
that and also to free up RS Ari's so
that they could focus on other tasks
rather than having to build the platform
themselves so at cruise we also have a
hybrid private network which kind of
biased a bunch of our decision-making we
already are in this complex multi cloud
world where we have AWS and GCP and
on-premise resources and so connecting
all this thankfully the platform team
didn't have to do by ourselves we have a
mid-engine that works with us and a good
security team that integrates with all
of us to sort of build out this this
private networking platform but there's
a whole bunch of other pieces underneath
kubernetes that you need to be concerned
about and make sure that those are also
set up to be multi-tenant one of the
ways we did that was by as was
recommended having separate projects for
separate environments but we also did a
full during structure so that we can
completely isolate our production
environments and be able to audit which
which like projects in GCP were
production projects that way we could
easily go see what their security state
was what the logs were for the
production stuff and and mostly security
and
other teams that were going and doing
audits didn't have to pay attention as
much to the development because it was
completely isolated so we did these
these folders and then we have teams
that had a set of projects and then
these projects are in each of the the
folders there's probably multiple team
folders so one of the things that get
put in these folders or these projects
that are in the folders is like net n
j-- manages its own networking
infrastructure inside their own projects
and then they share that network with
the other projects so none of the other
projects even have a default network
local to those projects they just share
the the one that's managed centrally and
then the teams would want to use their
own SAS products sometimes they use GCE
stuff as well
so cloud sequel is a good example of
having your database inside of your
team's project so only the team has
access to that data the platform team
doesn't need or want access to your
production data the net inch team
probably doesn't either
so it keeps a good isolation between
teams and then this also means that the
the PA's team or the platform team can
handle the kubernetes clusters inside
their own project which means that while
we have control of those projects people
outside of the central team don't have
access to come play around with the
kubernetes settings they just get access
to the kubernetes that's running on it
so in kubernetes in gke we also sort of
emulated this matrix of multi-tenancy so
we have dev staging and prod shared
clusters and we also have namespaces
that are assigned to those teams
so this satisfied a good sort of MVP
goal of getting everybody to only be
able to see what they needed access to
so each of them will run their pods
their pods are isolated across
environments and they're semi isolated
between teams as well so the teams
aren't stepping on each other's toes so
this was just a picture of some of the
pieces we put together I think Paz is a
little bit of a controversial term but
in our context gke by itself is not
enough we put a whole bunch of extra
work in integrations into providing a
platform for our internal tenants so
some of that is GCE components most of
these little ones and boxes are GC or
our GC P components or
configurations so we have public and
private load balancing routes which are
a little bit different because GCP has
different functionality for different
features and then we control those with
controllers that are then integrating
with gke and then those controllers
either have annotations or CR DS that
are in the kubernetes api so that our
tenants can self-service into the
selection of those features we also have
a whole bunch of security observability
and deployment functionality that we
provide as a service to our internal
tenants and that means that they don't
have to reinvent the wheel every time
and obviously we didn't just stamp all
this out on day one it was sort of a
growing experience we've been doing this
for over a year now and we moved to gke
about nine months ago so we we took some
of it from our existing deployments and
some of it we're still bidding out like
the external DNS up there is like a
controller for managing your DNS records
we don't have that ematic at the moment
we're still doing terraforming so vault
integration is one of the things that we
did early with help from our infrasound
and our infrastructure management eddie
secrets primarily because it provides a
source of truth separate from an
individual cluster and this is a concern
when you have multiple clusters if
you're small enough that you can survive
on one cluster and you don't want to
have multiple clusters per environment
then you can just use kubernetes
kubernetes secrets but when you have
this proliferation of clusters you have
to start concerning yourself about
single source of truth external to the
cluster and integrations so this is a
fairly standard pattern our sort of
contribution to that is a Daytona init
container that we wrote that authorizes
with vault and downloaded the secrets
using let me step back it logs into
vault using the service account in your
that's injected into your kubernetes pod
so that's a default kubernetes feature
and then a vault configuration feature
that's baked in and then Daytona we
added that does sort of the glue to
stick it together it uses an in-memory
Volume that's to make sure it doesn't
write anything to disk and it won't get
persisted outside of the lifecycle your
pod and then it slurps it in through an
app container volume mount so that you
can either read it from your application
or your application can have an entry
point script that converts from like a
file to an environment variable so
another thing we did is GCP service
account integration through vault so as
was mentioned the pod identity feature
was not available when we started doing
this and so one of the things this
allows us to do is provide the the pods
with their own identity from vaults
using a GCP service account so that
means that we can authorize these things
before the pod exists and the pod can go
out and perform GCP actions and probably
the primary one is talking to the
database so they use that with a sidecar
proxy to talk to you cloud sequel for
example so once you get into this sort
of central managing of vault you end up
having to manage your namespaces in
vault a little more carefully you can't
just have everybody writing secrets
wherever they want so what we went with
was some prefix that's specific to us
and then sort of a name spacing pattern
that allows for isolating the
environments and the namespace and the
application secrets which means that I
can say this team has permission to
write to all of the environment secrets
for all of the applications under their
namespace but other teams don't have
access to even see or list those and
then the application itself only has
access to see the secrets for its
environment for that specific app for
that namespace and that allows us to
granularly control permissions in vault
we ended up doing a sort of get up get
ups workflow to provision vault
configuration in order to enable that
another thing we did was group our own
binding so we wrote this about six more
open sourced it about six months ago and
this was to make up for the lack of role
binding which is a beta feature now for
Google Groups but it didn't used to
exist and we built in a couple more
features into this so so one of the
things that was explained earlier is
that you can't necessarily use the
project level role roles in order to
bind at the namespace level so what we
had to do was build out namespace admin
namespace editor and namespace viewer
and give those to individual groups so
we map those two groups and the team
gets that group membership that means I
can have a google group and there's some
manager that owns it and the manager
just goes adds new team members or
removes team members that leaves and
then they don't have to perform a role
binding manually this are back sync
functionality is a controller that will
watch a configuration in a CR D and the
CR D says this group gets this
permission and so then it will map that
out to the bindings by reading through
Google Groups to figure out who's in the
group another functionality that we
stuffed into this was the ability to put
service accounts in groups because
currently Google Groups don't support
that so what that means is that we can
give a service account a specific role
and then add it to a group whenever we
make a new service account so we can use
GCP service accounts to do that rather
than just kubernetes service accounts so
there's a couple things that are sort of
unsolved or you know bleeding edge
problems that we're still kind of trying
to work on so one of those is kubernetes
operators in a tendancy environment the
CR d's are global definitions and
kubernetes so you can't necessarily
allow your namespace tenants to create
CRD definitions they you so what we we
do is we as a cluster operating team
deploy CRD definitions and then allow
them to make CRD resource objects in
their namespace but that means you can
only have one sort of permutation of
that CRD at a time because CR DS weren't
designed for multi-tenancy so that means
we're effectively helping people deploy
operators also the container registry is
tenant ten
at the the level of Google projects or
GCP projects rather so if you want full
isolation between teams every team has
to manage their own GCR otherwise what
we do is we host a central one for
development purposes and give everybody
like admin to it that means they have
push and delete functionalities and then
everybody can push to that but we don't
allow pulling from that for the
production cluster so our production
cluster we only give access to service
accounts and those service accounts are
then used in continuous integration or
core building so all of the containers
that run on our production environment
we know we're pushed from CI Strad
driver logging also is tenet eyes at the
project level and because you have a
shared cluster that means that all of
the logs from all of your containers are
emitted to the same shared project which
creates a little bit of a problem
because we've only given people view
access to that project we didn't want to
give them editor access to step on each
other's toes which means they can't make
log to metric conversions or log
dashboards so in order to enable that we
had to build a fan-out system that will
take fluid fluid D stackdriver
and emits to other projects from
specific namespaces data dark metrics we
use data dog instead of sack driver for
our metrics right now and primarily that
allows us to aggregate them all but it's
also not super multi-tenant so you might
have both a fan out and a fan in problem
with both logging and metrics because
your auditors might want to see all of
them and your teams just want to see the
ones they care about so GCP has the
ability to like slurp all your logs into
one auditing project so we we use that
for auditing and then we use this other
fan-out solution for the tenants
spinnaker is another one where we had to
build our own Rob operator to make
spinnaker more isolated because we have
so many namespaces we have like 20
namespaces per cluster and maybe a dozen
clusters that means that that we are
doing a count binding and role binding
in spinnaker to isolate who can deploy
to what
spinnaker which is a little complicated
and then on resource isolation probably
one of the weaknesses of kubernetes in
general for multi-tenancy is that there
are some things that are not well
isolated yet so like CPU and memory are
great they're isolated you opt into it
and then you have that amount of
resource
it even has preemption on those but like
local disk space there's a beta feature
in kubernetes that isn't in gke yet so
we can't isolate that yet disk i/o is
completely uh nice elated in kubernetes
so if you are on spinning hard drives
which I don't recommend you can actually
knock over the docker daemon if you use
too much disk at the same time so we
switched to SSDs and that is mostly
eliminated the problem but it's it's
still uh nice elated ingress and egress
I mentioned us having solved those sort
of at the platform level but they're
also a little bit on isolated one of the
ways we're hoping to get towards
isolation in the future here is with
with Sto so SDO adds the sidecars to
each container and allows you to monitor
the ingress and egress from every
container which allows you to do sort of
traffic management but kubernetes
doesn't come with that by default so
there's a whole bunch of things we also
want to do that we haven't done just to
sort of be an example of all of the
things that you might want to consider
when you're building not just a
kubernetes cluster but a multi tenant
multi environment private cloud hybrid
network cluster so one of the things I
would recommend is to put in your
defaults and quotas before you put
tenants on your system because what
we've learned is now that we've gone and
had people on our systems we can't add
quotas without breaking them so we have
to do an analysis on like who's using
what and then make them per namespace
quotas and then add like a get-ups
approval process and all that kind of
stuff
so that's a little complicated do that
upfront we would also like to go to
project isolation instead of team
isolation and what I mean by that is
reducing the blast radius of compromised
project so if someone comes in through a
web app API or something compromised as
a web app and then they have like
control over the container for whatever
like one weakness in your application
you don't want it to be on the same
network in the same namespace
with everything else that team is
running you want to sort of reduce the
blast radius so there's a bunch of
different ways to do that one of them is
with by having smaller namespaces and
another one is by doing the sort of
network policy that restricts who has
access to what another one is with pod
security policy with reducing what the
pods can actually do and then a couple
of these other functionalities web hooks
have been talked a lot about about a
bunch in the kubernetes environment for
or ecosystem for sort of restraining or
enforcing what people can apply to your
cluster but there's no sort of office
off-the-shelf solution for that there's
there's Opa which is a policy sort of
administrator that can do some web hooks
for you but the Politan policies that
you can just slap in place so there's
some work to be done there and then we
would also like an automated build
system I'd really love like a docker hub
automated build for on premise behind my
firewall but it doesn't really exist so
there's a couple of different products
you can use a cloud builder as one of
them can ADA build is another one so
we're going to be working on that micro
segmentation of the network also reduces
blast radius security would love us to
get to that we're hoping to get there
with sto and network policies and usage
media metering was talked about it's
great we're gonna get there but like
because it is still beta we haven't
played with it yet and then service our
back is also kind of important with your
users to services or user to kubernetes
that's built in with gke you get you get
your Google user off and then you can do
role binding against users but once your
application is running
how do your applications authorize with
each other and this is kind of a problem
everybody has to solve and there's no
sort of out-of-the-box solution that I
know of yet and two n TLS is another one
gke doesn't come with this built-in you
can use sort of a let's let's encrypt
controller solution but we wanted one
that would allow us to do both public
and private domains so then we need to
host our own CA and automate the
controller for it and then make it
different from the
like one that kind of thing plus we
don't really want to be inserting TLS
certificates into every pod we'd rather
inject to the load balancer and then
have service mesh handle the last mile
encryption that way we're not putting
secrets that can be compromised down
into the pods we have sort of a two
layer encryption scheme so basically
more of a story if you're if you're big
enough to build a platform here on top
of kubernetes which kubernetes is a
platform for building platforms then
you're probably big enough to make it
multi-tenant multi-tenancy does require
additional work on top of kubernetes and
i wouldn't necessarily say it's for
everyone but if your alternative is
alternative is multi environment or
multi instance then you're gonna have to
build some layer underneath it that
allows you to deploy a bunch of clusters
and so if you're already building a
layer you might as well make it multi
tenant instead so there's obviously
trade-offs and pros and cons so take it
with a grain of salt but that's our
experience and I think we've got it
working pretty well if you go in a car
in crews or you see those driving around
those are all talking to our cloud with
the backend running on multi-tenant
kubernetes
Thank You Carl for sharing you know the
journey of cruise automation to using
kubernetes in a multi-tenant fashion i
just want to close out with a few key
sort of takeaways so you know by
centralizing kubernetes has a lot of
like learning that you have to do to
understand how to run it well and by
specializing that knowledge with one
team that operates your clusters not
only you know builds that sort of center
of excellence which allows you to
implement the best practices across
multiple clusters but it also frees up
your developers to spend their time on
developing stuff that that adds value to
your company so I think that's some of
the key takeaways and then it gives you
the operational efficiency by letting
that specialized team of two to manage
those clusters for you and it also saves
you some infrastructure cost by
consolidating a large number of clusters
into a fewer multi-tenant clusters as
well and GK has some new features that
can help you set up that multi-tenancy
as we heard from Karl and Cruz there's
still some work to be done and you know
you you'll see those features come out
as well
[Music]